[Music]
in counter-strike as in everything the
thing that makes perfect
is practice what are we talking about
practice that's right
practice the question of course is in an
esport as mechanically and strategically
sophisticated as cs go and with
countless custom community-made game
modes to choose from what aspect of your
game should you spend your time
improving maybe you're a movement
maestro and want to land crisp clean
hops that would make the almighty foon
himself
well swoon tremendous excuse me job of
doing so drop step trying to find dude
has he done that a man not known for
mechanics has evaded one of the world's
best nico gets absolutely destroyed it
could also be that you're like me and
spend every waking second banging out
retakes just so that every once in a
while you can really tell a kid to sit
the [ __ ] down
or maybe you're just super into surfing
and want to just well
vibe i mean let's not kid ourselves
surfing doesn't actually teach you
anything about counter-strike it's
just
[Music]
but there is one certifiable sheesh
factory for whom none of these
extracurricular activities are essential
and while every player does have their
quirks it just so happens that this one
is
well right now the reigning world number
one meet matsuya zaiwu ekbo a shy rosy
faced wonder kid who having been born on
the very day of counter-strike's first
ever retail release has long been
heralded as not only the savior of
french cs but the game's so-called
chosen one continuing to try and find
more ground continuing to try to fight
him from in the flames you can burn the
man alive but he's burnt around to a
crisp as xy who has to shine through in
a one-on-two he's got the first he's not
the second ty was the god he is above
anything else's can create but aside
from his destined birth date and innate
ability to own people there is one thing
about zaiwu that really sets them apart
you see while most phenoms spend
countless hours sharpening their skills
in death match or aim lab xaiwu doesn't
engage in anything outside of
counter-strike proper that encompasses
practicing per se he just
plays the game
all the time
and the weird thing is that the more you
examine his in human play style
the more it kind of shows an electronic
looking for the cleanest finish she's
been turned on
no health really but he's still hitting
shots he's already got three and four
and five and oh my god
[Music]
okay so before we dive into things
please do your boy dimitri a favor and
like the video subscribe to the channel
and turn on notifications so that you
never miss a future episode of offbeat
they really want me to shill out about
that last part okay so if you're into
esports and have no idea who zywoo is
you need to get your [ __ ] head out of
your ass absurdly hyped up and comer
turned explosive rookie turned two-time
topper of hltv's annual player rankings
it is pretty much impossible to
overstate just how unprecedented and
downright meteoric zywoo's rise to the
pinnacle of cs go really was team
there's twist poking his head out in the
toilet so i would trade another clutch
maybe
on the site cold hiding behind the truck
and now zai wu dancing left and right
he's got to pick his shot wisely he's
only got one chance
oh
oh my goodness but we're not here to
talk about zywoo's whole story beginning
to end if that's what you want then you
should
totally check out our story of zywoo
what we are here to talk about is the
fact that for the reigning number one
best cs go player in the world he's got
kind of a peculiar practice regimen you
see about seven months ago xy did an
interview with zak nani where he was
asked about his training routine since
presumably everyone wanted to know the
secret behind his monumental success
needless to say
the answer that he gave came as a
foreign
now if you're not intimately familiar
with tactical shooters such as
counter-strike valorant hell even siege
this might not seem all that weird to
you but let me assure you it is pretty
out of the ordinary especially at
xaiwu's level of play the vast majority
of first-person shooter competitors
whether seasoned or aspiring spend
countless hours perfecting their
mechanics in things like aim trainers
death match servers and bot maps their
reasoning being that the best way to
perform in an official is to grind
incessantly outside of one i was a die
hard deathmatch guy back in the days i
put in like what is it
four hour sessions at least per day for
a couple years and i think it's a
necessary tool for a player to use you
know but then you have
xy
um
[Music]
you see for a very long time the
accepted wisdom has been that you pretty
much have to death match in order to get
good at cs go in fact there's a long
history of scrubs sitting in lower tons
holding angles with a mag 7 wondering
why going 50 and 10 isn't making them
good
yeah man
the reason of course is that death match
is at its core
kind of a fiction
don't believe me just ask ddk
matchmaking or competitive counter
strike is not deathmatch they are two
separate things in terms of what they
require from you now that's not to say
that deathmatch servers aren't a useful
tool they are in truth there's pretty
much no better place to start mastering
things like movement spray patterns
pistol play and of course one taps
deathmatch is a great way to jump in a
server against like human targets and
like just mess around and practice
shooting without
feeling the need to get the kill you can
practice a style and be like it doesn't
matter if i kill him or not because i'm
just there's no consequence the
important thing to remember however is
that the tool that is death match
is is just that
a tool it doesn't matter how cracked you
are in these headshot only hangouts
where the stakes are low smokes don't
matter and the only thing you have to
worry about is getting spawn killed by
silvers deathmatch isn't counter-strike
and pretending it is
won't get you anywhere playing good
counter-strike is about creating as many
advantageous fights as possible you
never want to be in a position to make a
lot of flashy shots what zywu did was
validate that mindset like never before
see unlike the vast majority of
counter-strike's sickest crack shots
xaiwu isn't especially known for his aim
don't get me wrong he does have great
aim and can flick with the best of them
he's just not one of these literal
[ __ ] aimbots whose pc needs to be
checked every five minutes oh here we go
god i'm not oh
what
oh that's the badger what zywoo is known
for
is his otherworldly
game sense he isn't just an intelligent
player he is the perfect player this kid
doesn't just suss out your location he
freaking divines it it's as if his
actual mind has wall hacks as if he
knows where and when you're going to be
before you do cyborg a lot of time i see
him especially in high pressure
situations i i see him he's got
obviously a lot of flick but i do see
him sometimes sort of reading the game
at a what looks to me like a slightly
deeper level but it has to be the 1v4
clutch from zyward nearly comes in
barely
enough health to survive here on brawler
but xavier wants to kill there's the
headshot pulls it back and the open side
who's got the triple krimz is the last
man standing and there's time for the
defuse cyber wants to smoke the bomb if
you're crips you have to be scared and
zombie wins it it's just remarkable that
his brain just works in that way and i
think a lot of people's brain also works
like that but they're not fully using it
the whole way it's just like he's just
seeing
you know every prediction beforehand the
best part is that because of this zywoo
isn't really all that flashy of a player
like he's surgical but not much of a
showboat which might have to do with how
let's say
reserved he is
outside of the server zyru what is it
like being in front of this amazing
crowd
i don't know
what do you think of shazam just said
trolling with zeus
[Laughter]
have you got anything to ask
no nothing okay needless to say the kid
is a bit of an anomaly as one caster so
elegantly put it he just walks around
and hits shots well they're anticipating
banana from the looks of the guy over
here it's gonna be sideways that rings
out first
he's had enough he's gonna keep going
through it he doesn't really care again
freakishness even gave way to a now
infamous esports wide copy pasta which i
mean let's be honest
really captured the sussness of his
intuitions cause like zyru skilled
player but that is not normally this
very very insane they need to check him
pc and game maybe he's not cheating but
maybe he using the game deficit and this
can't seem on game screen he needs to
check up sideways i'm on a few words
what have you got to say about winning
this game
no no
anyway memes aside
how is it that zywu is able to do what
he does well for starters there is
clearly some sense in which he was just
born with it you cannot be that young
and that competitively inexperienced and
just saunter your way to two
back-to-back hltv number ones unless
some divine being blessed you with the
business end of an op i was one of the
first guys thinking that he was cheating
like when we were because i used to play
him back in the lower tier of our scene
and it's not until you actually play
with him and speak to him that you
understand that the guy just doesn't see
things the same way as we do i could
like imagine in his brain it's just like
the matrix so he got numbers coming down
like okay he was here at one point so he
could be here here here and then he just
checks those two angles and he's in one
of them and he kills it that's how
that's how it feels but even if you are
the mozart of counter-strike and were
fated to coast your way into the highest
level of play
you still need to put in countless hours
if you have any intention of staying
there like all aspiring competitors
xaiwu spends an insane amount of time
practicing his craft but what separates
him from the fray it seems is that he
efficiently invests those hours where
they matter most
fast
forward
[Music]
thanks in part to his pug centric
upbringing and practice regime xy has
both pioneered and popularized a
playstyle in which game sense is
prioritized over gun skill because at
the end of the day you can deathmatch to
your heart's content but it won't teach
you how to use utility how to
communicate how to clutch
how to overcome ladder anxiety those are
the things that'll make for a truly
excellent counter-strike player and
isn't that kind of the point zy woo
peeking up middle simultaneously shocks
comes in he was the
best performing player on nuke
and a pretty rough bunch if we're being
honest then glaive's got a fourth he
could be on for the ace but fly who
takes it away from him 30 seconds low hp
has the bomb but no idea as to where the
remaining cts are flicking up into the
header device he has enough time to
feasibly clutch this he'll be playing
this one a little bit more passively a
little bit more patiently hell just give
this fight away to zai wu wait for the
cavalry to arrive make sure you double
peek him simultaneously zai who's so
nearly lands to no scope but on one hp
he's still alive he's still here he's
still kicking
and you cannot disrespect this woman
because he will punish you
storms i will comes in and leaves
nothing but carnage and his weight
that's outrageous
i have a couple of nice one taps in the
footage i sent you you can uh pop one in
there
oh you're so bad no i think the viewers
might want you that white might want to
see a little little crispy one-tap
action
your trash your trash literally [ __ ]
dog [ __ ]